do you know who Andrew Tate is he is
part of human trafficking or something
like that what people keep saying that
he does human trafficking but he hasn't
been charged with anything at all
because he left the country now so the
allegation was in Romania but there's no
evidence at all yeah but like even what
he says in his video I've watched a
little on Tick Tock as a feminist I
don't appreciate how he talks about
women how do you know that he treats
women badly he talks about it in his
video can you give me an example because
I haven't seen him say anything bad or
mean towards women really because I've
met him personally and I've never
experienced anything negative and all
you guys are have seen is through Tick
Tock yeah okay but if you met him for a
few minutes no I know we're friends he's
a friend he's a good friend I've met him
plenty of time do you not think there's
a problem with judging people from what
you see on the internet things have been
taken out of context I've saw just a lot
of content about him that was negative
but like what can you give me an example
I don't know I like I said it was a few
months ago because now it's the the the
thing around him is a little over